now for many years now uh
democrats have realized that the only
way to turn their radical plans into a
reality
is to take more power and money from the
american people
and give it to washington they want
control
over almost every aspect of your life
we can't uh drive our suvs
and you know eat as much as we want and
keep our
homes on you know 72 degrees at all
times
can't do any of those things he said
back in 2008 and all these years later
we see obama's heirs carrying on his
mission control in the same way that we
have taxed
cigarettes we're going to have to tax
carbon we have to take
the take combustion engine vehicles off
the road
as rapidly as we can would you support
changing the dietary guidelines
yes reduce red meat specifically yes i
would
now remember the left believes that
america isn't
exceptional it's systemically racist and
that means
we shouldn't be any better off than the
rest of the world so the greeniac saw an
opening when the global economy due to
covid cratered last year
because of the lockdowns closures and
reduced demand
carbon emissions fell by about 2.6
billion metric tons which was a seven
percent drop from the year prior
climate change activists who ignored or
dismissed the human suffering caused by
these draconian covert rules
were positively giddy that kids were
harmed from the cancellation of
in-person learning and athletics was
simply not relevant
given the left's larger long-term goal
of reducing america's carbon footprint
so they saw covet as an opportunity to
advance the interest
of a global climate bureaucracy their
pet media
marveled about the environmental
benefits of lockdowns
again ignoring human suffering
if there is a silver lining to this
crisis is visible
in the skies above china all of this
inaction while causing so many humans
problems
has actually proven to be quite good for
mother earth
falling pollution levels brought about
by lockdowns may have
been shining an impact on sunshine wild
animals are now roaming city streets
how do we make sure these pollution
levels don't rebound
so the longer you were behind closed
doors not commuting to work
not going to church not traveling to see
family
the happier those people were
but having a free country means that
individuals are making their own risk
assessments
according to their own risk profiles
the greeniacs hate that they much prefer
to order you around or
if that's not possible to frighten you
into abandoning your own common sense
so mindless coveted fear-mongering kept
suburban women double-masked on running
trails
and sent urbanites to amazon prime for
all their grocery orders
my favorite is when they were
frantically wiping down their bananas
and their egg cartons worried about
coven no the virus can live on surfaces
for example
stealing plastic for up to three days
i'm just going to clean
all the virus off here i don't need to
do too much it's a pretty sensitive
virus for cardboard it's typically going
to be closer
to 24 hours
of course none of that was true right
but he did do a good job of cleaning
but after some fits and starts we won
the kova debate
their so-called public health experts
were wrong on everything from lockdowns
to masks to social distancing those
measures inflicted enormous economic
educational and psychological harm to
adults and children alike
and biden's attempt to take credit for
th this not withstanding
it was trump who greenlit operation warp
speed
yet now we see the usual suspects lining
up to exploit
another hyped crisis of course i'm
talking about climate change
and the end goal is the same they want
more of your money and your freedom
and if they have to take extreme
measures to accomplish this
oh they will unless we're ready for them
so if we apply the lessons learned in
our battle against the covet lockdowns
i'm confident we can stop them and we
can win this
if you think the force is propping up
biden aren't thinking about declaring a
climate emergency in some form during
its first term
you haven't been paying close attention
a report released yesterday by the
international energy agency
gave us a sneak preview of what might be
coming
and of course the lockdowns gave them
the perfect road map
for how to exert control over the
population
don't take my word for it they admit
this
the coven crisis demonstrated that
people can make behavioral changes
at significant speed and scan scale if
they understand the changes to be
justified
now will we be ordered to stay at home
because of the climate
well perhaps not the left is real you
know rarely that straightforward
but even without government stay-at-home
orders there are a lot of ways for the
left to effectively lock you down
like through gasoline shortages
skyrocketing fuel prices
phase outs of gas-powered cars just to
name a few
in fact the ieae's bucket list of
climate controls includes carbon taxes
fuel taxes
limiting air travel reducing speed
limits phasing out
gas powered cars and many more
agenda items doesn't that just sound
grand san francisco among other cities
is seriously considering implementing
congestion
congestion pricing with fees as high as
14
for every car entering the city
new york and dc are already squeezing
cars out by expanding
bike and pedestrian lanes hawaii they've
already declared a climate emergency
there
and the far left is already pressuring
biden to declare one
on a national scale aoc and bernie
sanders
introduced legislation back in february
in fact
to do just that but we cannot let the
politicians or the bureaucrats abuse
their authority again
no more never-ending states of emergency
no more executive orders to shutter
businesses and schools
if governors or mayors want more
authority
then they should ask for the voters to
approve that
you know pass a law the old-fashioned
way through the state legislature
pennsylvania voters offer a blueprint
for stopping future abuses of emergency
orders by governors
who of course enjoyed exerting their
unchecked authority
to shutter schools and businesses in a
rebuke of democrat governor tom
wolf 54 percent of voters yesterday
supported a ballot question to allow
a simple majority of lawmakers to end a
disaster declaration at any time
democrats and so-called public health
experts use remember half true
skewed data and outright lies to
pressure states
to make the drastic decision to lock
down
only seven resisted
only one state south dakota didn't order
any businesses to close during the
pandemic
georgia was the first to reopen then
florida and mississippi and others
followed suit
they brushed off the dire warnings and
the power mad coveokrats
these governors put the overall
interests of their residents
and the long-term survival of their
states ahead of the alarmism of the
moment
this is the same approach that we need
to take when they throw the climate
hyperbole
at us as usual if we want to see where
the democrats are going
look to europe in milan they're pushing
cars out of there with
bike and pedestrian lanes fuel taxes are
being jacked up
all over the uk and europe and france
is moving to ban all short-haul domestic
flights
to stop this nonsense from happening
here we need to
aggressively push back at every turn
just like pennsylvania
did yesterday just like we did with
covet
and just like we're doing with critical
race theory in our schools and we're
winning that as well
the only lockdown that should happen
again is of the politicians who try to
rest away
liberties and hard-earned money on the
bogus claim that government can solve
every problem when we know all too often
government just makes matters worse and
that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else